I just want to mention we're doing very
well in terms of the summit with North
Korea looks like it's going along very
well there as you know there are
meetings going on as we speak in a
certain location which I won't name
we're looking at June 12th in Singapore
that hasn't changed
I think it's possible to have a
constructive and positive summit and I
certainly prefer president Trump's
choice now of diplomacy over threatening
fire in fury
I'd love to see them denuclearize I just
I'm not very optimistic about that
so the on-again-off-again may be on
again North Korea's summit with that
let's bring in our panel
Tom Rogan commentary writer for the
Washington Examiner Karen Tumulty
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist Molly your thoughts on where
we are with whether or not this summits
going to happen on or around June 12th
well I it would certainly be amazing if
we could make that June 12th meeting in
part because we just learned last week
that we haven't had a lot of good
discussions with North Korea about the
terms of what would be discussed at a
summit and there is good reason to be
skeptical about North Korea because we
have had so many times of meeting with
them of them promising not to proceed
with their nuclear ambitions only to
have them break their word now that they
have finally achieved their long-held
goal of nuclearization I think we have a
lot that we need to learn about what
they hope to get in exchange for their
claim that they will do karai's speaking
of that we've heard some bipartisan
skepticism or concern from lawmakers
let's take a listen it's right out of
the North Korean playbook we're into
three generations of that playbook now
act like you want to negotiate then come
up with some outlandish view of what
that negotiation means and try to wind
up with early of benefits to your side
and not following following through on
what you've agreed to do twice before
North Korea under Kim jong-un's father
committed to full denuclearization in
six-party talks in 2005 in 2007 as
Senator blunt just referenced only to
then change their tune so a lot of folks
from both parties favor
King there is at least posh and right
Karen I think to this this go round
after after we saw the president sort of
run up to this once before it the way
it's going about looks a lot more
professional than the first time the
president is actually letting the pros
his foreign policy team get in there and
kind of lay the groundwork there's a lot
more message discipline coming out of
this administration no premature talk of
Nobel prizes this time and I think also
one other thing that's going to be
really important here is kind of setting
some realistic expectations for these
talks as opposed to thinking that
somehow you know by the force of his
personality President Trump can bring
about full denuclearization you know in
his first meeting is the most likely
scenario Tom they come out of a meeting
and say we've had a good discussion
we've made some steps toward resolving
this issue now we're gonna continue
working it is that is that most likely I
think that's the ideal scenario for the
Chinese and the North Koreans the ideal
scenario for President Trump and I think
you see this in terms of how the
administration is framing it is to at
least get something immediately out of
that summit whether that be a limited
and inspections trip by the IAEA into
North Korea whether it be a declaration
in terms of the ballistic missile stuff
that we know they've been doing on the
warhead research something tangible and
and if I think the good thing about this
that skepticism rendering that American
expectation of something tangible means
that if you don't get something tangible
then president Trump will go back to the
sort of maximum pressure approach
because it will be pretty clear that the
North Koreans are doing what they have
done before which is to say playing
games the South Korean president talked
about the message he was delivering over
the weekend to the North Koreans take a
listen to this turn on turn on Joseph
Don I explained to North Korean leader
Kim jong-un the results of my meeting
with US President Trump from last week
and delivered the message that President
Trump has a strong will for putting an
end to hostile relations and help
achieve economic prosperity provided
chairman Kim makes a decision for
complete denuclearization and carries it
out so there was a lot of speculation
this past week that president moon was
coming here and would be taking a
message with him now it's
like he did deliver a mess of Drake time
yes I'm I think that's true I also think
the Chinese here the there has been a
flip that the Chinese were trying to
test the waters here with President
Trump by telling the North Koreans play
games and now that in the context of
President Trump playing hardball with
then on trade
they want us concessions in the South
China Sea as part of their quid pro quo
for pressuring Pyongyang president Trump
is playing that game of unpredictability
I mean this is the one issue I do think
with the Twitter feed and the slight you
know strangeness of it all serve as a
positive interest because it throws
foreign part foreign nations who are to
have a different political structure to
our own off balance in terms of their
perception of what Trump might do Karen
we know an advanced team from the u.s.
went to North Korea to meet to talk
about this so it sounds like they're
hopeful and again like I said they're
sending the pros in to lay the
groundwork but I think president moon
has been in a lot of ways the most
interesting person to watch in all of
this he does seem to be kind of the most
skillful at kind of reading all the the
interests and sort of sort of bringing
everybody along Molly how do you think
the next couple of weeks play out with
this well I'm not sure but I just wanna
say I think it's also worth pointing out
that it wasn't that the US was not eager
to meet or that the u.s. wasn't trying
to make terms for what the summit would
be but that North Korea wasn't showing
that to you it's also the president sort
of getting out of his own foreign policy
team in fact by announcing this meeting
before he even discussed with his own
foreign policy team what he was going to
do that really did kind of limit the
amount of groundwork that could be done
whether you think it's limiting or
whether you think that kind of pressure
is actually helpful I mean you're seeing
also in South Korea it's putting a lot
of pressure on people they're very eager
to move things forward and you're seeing
this I mean I think even in the in
president Trump's letter last week you
got a sense he said something like we
were told by South Korea that you wanted
to me we were told by South Korea that
North Korea wanted to meet
he kind of suggested that maybe they
weren't confident in what South Korea
was saying there has been so much that
communicated through South Korea and
even today they're showing such
eagerness I think that's interesting
this is clearly in their interest to get
a deal going also President Trump talked
with AH BAE today Japan is very
interested in getting things going China
as Tom points out I think is the
interesting
party here we're not gonna get a deal
unless they're on board I don't think
we've learned a lot or enough yet about
what their interests are what they hope
to accomplish